the jurogan experience if categories
just just dissolve especially
fundamental ones
the culture is dissolving because the
culture is a structure of category
that's what it is
so and in fact culture is a strat
culture is a
structure of category that we all share
so we see things the same way well
that's why we can talk i mean not
exactly the same way because then we'd
have nothing to talk about but
roughly speaking we have a bedrock of
agreement
that's the bible by the way
so i just walked through the museum of
the bible in washington that was very
cool it's a very cool museum so the
structure that's what the bible is what
i figured out i mean i just figured this
out this week
so it was a cool
it was a cool thing to walk through
because
it's it's chronological they have one
floor which is the history of the bible
it's not exactly that it's really what
it is is the history of the book
now in many ways the first book was the
bible i mean literally
because
at one point there was only one book
like as far as our western culture is
concerned there was one book and for a
while literally there was only one book
and that book was the bible and then
before it was the bible it was a you
know scrolls and it was writings on
papyrus and but it was we were starting
to aggregate written texts together and
it went through all sorts of
technological transformations and then
it became
books that everybody could buy the book
everybody could buy and the first one of
those was the bible and then it became
all sorts of books that everybody could
buy
but all those books in some sense
emerged out of that underlying book and
that book itself the bible isn't a book
it's a library
it's a collection of books
and so
what i figured out was partly because i
was talking to my brother-in-law jim
keller who's
the world's greatest chip designer and
has now designed a chip
that's as powerful as the human brain
which is optimized for artificial
intelligence learning by the way and so
i talked to him about that he said you
heard of the internet
i said yeah jim i've heard of the
internet he said
this is way more revolutionary than that
so in any case we were talking about
meaning in text because we were talking
about translation and the problem of
understanding text and jim said
the meaning of words is coded in the
relationship of the words to one another
and the postmodernists make that case
that all meaning is derived from the
relationship between words that's wrong
because
well what about rage that's not words
and what about moving your hand that's
not words so it's wrong but but part of
it's right because
the meaning we derive from the verbal
domain is encoded in the relationship
between words
so
so now then you think well let's think
about the relationship between words
well some words are dependent on other
words some ideas are dependent on other
ideas
the more ideas are dependent on a given
idea the more fundamental that idea is
that's a definition of fundamental
so now imagine you have an aggregation
of texts in a civilization you say which
are the fundamental texts and the answer
is
the texts upon which most other texts
depend and so you put shakespeare way in
there in english because so many texts
are dependent on shakespeare's literary
revelations and milton would be in that
category and dante would be in that
category at least in translation
fundamental authors part of the western
canon not because of the arbitrary
dictates of power
but because those texts influenced more
other texts and then you think about
that as a hierarchy
okay with the bible at its base which is
certainly the case
now imagine that's the entire corpus of
of linguistic production all things
considered
now how do you understand that like
literally how do you understand that the
answer is you sample it by reading and
listening to stories and listening to
people talk you sample that whole domain
you build a low resolution
representation of that in your inside
you
and then you listen and see
through that
and so it isn't that the bible is true
it's that the bible is the precondition
for the manifestation of truth
which makes it way more true than just
true
it's a whole different kind of true and
i think this is i think this is not only
literally the case
factually i think it can't be any other
way
it's the only way we can solve the
problem of perception